[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans Sciences publiques 90
minutes de débat de reportage et
d'expertise 90 minutes et deux thèmes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité et aux
mutations de notre société et voici le
sommaire de ceux trois mai le référendum
d'initiative partagée de nouveau à la
Une de lecture avec la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel ce RIP est-il
une fausse promesse de démocratie
directe la réforme des retraites
peut-elle encore être retoquée comment
redonner du souffle à notre cinquième
république la verticalité du pouvoir
était liée à la seule personnalité
d'Emmanuel Macron on répond à toutes ces
questions dans une minute et puis
c'était le 8 avril
1973 la mort de Pablo Picasso un
demi-siècle plus tard faut-il faire de
2023 l'année Picasso plusieurs voix
s'élèvent pour rappeler que l'artiste
génial était aussi un ogre violent
psychologiquement et physiquement avec
les femmes
bien sûr dire qu'un il y a eu des
choses épouvantables il adopte un enfant
avec Fernand et puis on va le rendre à
l'orphelinat enfin vous imaginez il fait
des choses
abracadabra dans un esprit de j'ai tous
les deux et il a tous les droits et on
lui laisse tous les droits peut-on
séparer l'homme de l'artiste faut-il
boycotter Picasso comment respecter les
femmes éliminités sans tomber dans les
excès de la cancel culture ne ratez pas
notre débat dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord au delà de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel on détaille les
leviers qui restent dans les mains des
opposants à la réforme des retraites
avec Cécile Sixou
ils ont annoncé une grille à
parlementaire députée et sénateurs de
gauche ont utilisé tous les moyens à
leur disposition pour obtenir le retrait
de la réforme des retraites hier lors
des questions d'actualité à l'Assemblée
la nupesse a donné le temps on ne fait
pas terre le peuple on l'écoute on ne le
méprise pas on le respectent on ne leur
imprime pas on lui obéit nous ne
céderons pas elle compte faire de
l'hémicycle son terrain de bataille
contre la réforme et attend le 8 juin
prochain la discussion de la proposition
de loi déposée par le groupe liote pour
abroger la réforme le vote que le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu avoir une
première fois et bien nous puissions
l'avoir cette fois-ci et montrer que ce
gouvernement n'a ni majorité dans la rue
ni dans le monde syndical c'est une
évidence mais pas davantage à
l'Assemblée les sénateurs de gauche
aussi veulent mettre la pression sur le
gouvernement le groupe communiste a
également déposé une proposition de loi
pour aborder la réforme continuons à
amener cette bataille et puis si celle
du groupe liotte à l'Assemblée nationale
passe et bien nous demanderons à ce
qu'elle soit inscrites d'urgence à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat donc la
bataille parlementaire n'est pas chimie
loin sans faut comme d'ailleurs à la
bataille sociale avec les mobilisations
qui se poursuivent et l'intersyndicale
qui reste unique la proposition de loi
communisme devra attendre car le groupe
n'a plus de créneaux lors de cette
session et les socialistes à qui il
reste une niche le 15 juin ne souhaite
pas l'inscrire à l'ordre du jour cette
proposition de loi que je soutiens
naturellement du mot communiste a
tellement peu de chance de passer que il
faut être ce garder d'utiliser nos
niches finalement un débat qui n'est pas
inutile mais qui n'aboutira pas sur le
plan du fond donc j'espère que à
l'Assemblée ils nous montreront le
chemin
lui réaccélérer ses réformes devra
encore attendre début juin pour changer
de séquence politique
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce débat de sciences
publiques Lucile Schmitt bonsoir
bienvenue bonsoir vous êtes
vice-présidente du sac de réflexion la
fabrique écologique et vous publiez
Emmanuel Macron à contretemps aux
éditions Bayard Benjamin Morel bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes constitutionnalisme
maître de conférence en droit public à
Paris de Panthéon Assas Richard Werly
bonsoir bonsoir pendant France heureux
pour le média Suisse Blake pays qui
utiliser régulièrement le référendum on
en parlera évidemment longuement dans ce
dans ce débat et Mathieu croissanto
éditoris politique bonsoir bonsoir
Mathieu je voudrais qu'on démarre sur
cette espèce de de double tempo dans
l'actualité en ce moment là on vient de
voir un sujet sur les les armes entre
les mains des opposants pour continuer
de contredire cette réforme de retraite
puis à côté de ça on a un gouvernement
qui annonce un président qui annonce les
100 jours un gouvernement qui annonce
des réformes qui fait presque comme si
la page est était tournée comment
l'opinion peut réagir à une telle un tel
contraste lucide Schmitt
je crois qu'elle réagit avec le
sentiment que le monde du pouvoir est de
plus en plus éloigné du monde de la
réalité et ça évidemment c'est un vrai
sujet lorsqu'il s'agit de faire
fonctionner la démocratie puisque la
démocratie c'est être représentée par
des personnes auxquelles on peut
s'identifier donc cette séparation entre
le monde du pouvoir et la réalité je
pense qu'elle est extrêmement
préjudiciable à ce qu'on peut appeler la
vie démocratique et puis je pense que ce
qui est aussi intéressant c'est qu'à
travers les manifestations qui sont
déroulées des personnalités du monde
syndical évidemment tout le monde pense
à leur en berger mais au fond il y a eu
une il y a eu aussi un pouvoir collectif
syndical qui a émergé ont montré un
fonctionnement qui n'était pas le
fonctionnement politique classique mais
qui avait une portée politique et qui
était très différent c'est à dire qu'on
avait une capacité à parler simplement à
incarner une union et une collectivité
tandis que là on voit bien que le
gouvernement il obéit à Manuel Macron
que la verticalité au fond elle pèse
aussi sur le gouvernement et
qu'assemblée ceux qui ne sont pas de la
majorité baigne une guerre de marché et
que donc la question d'avoir une
fluidité puisque le terme est souvent à
la mode en tout cas de notre vie
parlementaire n'existe pas à la fois
sans doute parce qu'on a des habitudes
de bataille rangées en France mais aussi
parce que il y a une verticalité du
pouvoir et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que le
mouvement de contestation dans la rue il
a changé de forme il a changé presque
depuis le passage par le 49-3 on voit
que c'est moins la réforme des retraites
qui est visée que la la pratique du
pouvoir c'est ce sentiment qu'on a c'est
ce qu'on entend beaucoup dans les dans
les manifestations est-ce que c'est le
signe d'une cinquième république qui est
fatiguée qui est à bout de souffle
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous allez jusque
là alors il y a un problème
institutionnel il y a un problème plus
large le problème institutionnel il est
évident parce qu'en fait le 49 Elina 3
c'est quoi et vous avez montré tout à
l'heure les potentialités de révision de
cette réforme des retraites sans être
grand clair très peu ont une chance
d'arriver au bout on reviendra sans
doute sur le rythme
on va en parler
elle aura pas de majorité au Sénat donc
même quand vous avez une majorité de
Français qui est contre une loi et bien
l'impossibilité à se faire entendre
devient un problème démocratique la
cinquième c'est un régime bonapartiste
de Gaulle la pensée comme étant une
façon pour lui chef de l'État dans
l'appeler à peu au peuple contre le
Parlement seulement quand vous n'en
appelez pas au peuple que le peuple
s'opposait à vous et que vous n'avez pas
de majorité parlementaire vous retrouvez
dans un système qui malgré tout es
sclérosé après il faut pas non plus être
trop franco-centré regardez de la
Pologne aux États-Unis de la Suède on
parlait beaucoup des pays scandinaves il
y a quelques années au Portugal il y a
pas une démocratie aujourd'hui
occidentale qui va bien il va bien on
est dans une crise de la représentation
qui est profonde qui est liée à la
déstructuration de l'espace public
qu'elle y est également au sentiment
d'impotence du politique et donc ça
évidemment il peut y avoir des réponses
institutionnelles mais les réponses ne
sont peut-être pas d'abord ou en tout
cas ne sont pas que institutionnels
Richard Verly votre avis sur ce décalage
parce que c'est intéressant vous parliez
du décalage entre le les personnalités
représente le pouvoir aux enfants et les
demandes des Français mais c’est
exactement ce que la première ministre
Elisabeth borne cherche à faire dans la
feuille de route répondre elle dit je
veux du concret je veux des mesures à
hauteur d'homme mais on a l'impression
que ça n'imprime pas dans l'opinion
malgré tout alors le discours de Lisette
d'Élisabeth borne et ça fait deux routes
là je pense pour le coup qu'elle n'a pas
imprimé en tout cas on entend d'ailleurs
personne en parler moi je dis je suis
descendu à la manifestation de lundi
j'ai posé la question alors la feuille
de route qu'est-ce qui va être fait
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez personne
n'y prêtait même attention mais il faut
dire que ce qui était dans la rue
c'était les opposants donc moi ce qui me
frappe c'est qu'au fond les Français
l'ont très bien compris puisque
souvenez-vous dans les sondages il y
avait certes deux tiers un peu près 70%
hostile à la réforme de retraite mais
65% qui savaient qu'elle allait être
appliquée et que finalement il allait
entrer en vigueur c'est que les Français
ont intégré et c'est peut-être ça le
pire l'idée que de toute manière le
système va faire le système entre
guillemets va faire ce qu'il a prévu et
qu'ils ne seront pas entendus et vu d'un
pays comme la mais vu d'autres pays
européens c'est vraiment une
contradiction qui pose problème et qui
ne serait pas supportable cette idée
qu'au fond il y a d'un côté la machine
gouvernementale qui avance et de l'autre
la population qui bon gré malgré est
obligé de suivre et on va se poser
maintenant la question de des fausses
promesses peut-être sur la capacité ou
non des oppositions à bloquer cette
réforme des retraites vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement Mathieu je me tourne vers
vous parce que effectivement on va on va
s'intéresser maintenant à ce groupe
liotte à l'assemblée qui a déposé une
proposition de loi pour abroger la
réforme qui sera étudié le 8 juin à le
rappel et c'est pour ça aussi que la
prochaine journée de mobilisation a lieu
deux jours avant le 6 alors ce groupe
lyode cru hein le groupe parlementaire
qui fait trembler la macronie vous le
trouverez pas sur les bandes à l'UPS
vous trouverez pas sur ce du RN mais
c'est donc lui l'iode pour liberté
indépendante outre-mer et territoire un
long fourre-tout et pour cause parce
qu'on trouve de tout dans le groupe
pilote c'est un peu la Samaritaine du
Palais Bourbon un collectif une
vingtaine de députés venus d'horizon
divers centres droits centre gauche
décors des ultramarins des socialistes
en rupture de banque ça a été créé sous
la précédente législature en 2018 c'est
un drôle d'attelage et à l'origine
c'était ce qu'on appelle un groupe
technique au Parlement c'est à dire un
mariage de raison entre non inscrits
généralement pour pouvoir se doter à la
fois de moyen matériel ou d'un temps de
parole et ce groupe technique pardon
j'étais tellement je buvais vos paroles
que j'ai oublié ma relance il trouve là
maintenant une position politique
centrale oui parce que eux qui avaient
refusé à l'origine de se présenter soit
dans la majorité soit dans l'opposition
et il disait juste on a un groupe
minoritaire sont devenus un groupe
charnière dans une assemblée sans
majorité absolue alors là on se dit quel
retournement de situation parce que de
2018 à 2022 la majorité au pouvoir donc
la même enfin c'est le cas la majorité
relative aujourd'hui faisait quand même
peu de cas d'Elliott refusant par
exemple de les laisser siéger au centre
de l'hémicycle comme il demandait mais
en essayant de leur dire vous allez
aller plutôt là-haut à côté de la France
insoumise à l'extrême gauche de de
l'hémicycle et puis soudain faut quand
même le dire en 2022 mais patatras
nouvelle élections et la changement
d'air à la rentrée les liottes ont été
courtisés comme jamais par le
gouvernement qui espérait pouvoir y
trouver un réservoir de voix qui lui
manquait au point même quand même des
solaninement invités à constituer une
alliance par le Président de la
République en personne vous en souvenez
peut-être c'était la télévision le 26
octobre dernier je pense que tous les
Français ont découvert ou non
première fois qu'on a entendu cette
acronyme mais voilà l'Elliott se
rebiffent ces esprits n'ont pas un
tempérament de godillot un peu à l'image
de leur figure tutélaire le député de la
Marne Charles de Courson doyen du Palais
Bourbon puisque il a été élu sans
discontinué depuis
1993 on le sait lui c'est un contenteur
invétéré du pouvoir macroniste en
général et puis de la réforme des
retraites en particulier et avec ces
petits camarades ben ils ont déposé à la
fois une motion référent derrière puis
une motion de censure et puis désormais
cette proposition de loi qui vise à
abroger la réforme a-t-elle des chances
de passer
à l'Assemblée peut-être pourquoi mais
parce que l'absence de marque politique
de l'attelage liotte s'est transformé en
avantage dans une assemblée éclatée mais
très clivée et bien ils sont ceux
derrière lesquels toutes l'opposition
peut se rassembler du RNA elle et fille
en passant par les LR dissidents au
canal historique je sais pas comment le
dire ou en tout cas ceux qui sont pas
forcément dans les lignes
d'ericsiotiques l'héliath sont ne sont
plus quantités négligeables du coup mais
faire de lance et c'est quand même une
sacrée revanche quand on y pense alors
quand même Lucie Schmidt merci Mathieu
cette perspective de voir des députés
socialistes ou écologistes qui votent
avec les élus RN
[Musique]
ça vous gêne oui oui bien sûr ça me gêne
assez profondément après ce qui me gêne
encore davantage c'est bien sûr la façon
dont le président de la République et le
gouvernement n'ont pas voulu entendre
cette opposition vous l'évoquiez de 70%
enfin dans les sondages des Français
donc ce que je constate c'est un
dysfonctionnement profond dont
évidemment ça a été beaucoup dit au
moment de cette crise le rassemblement
national est sans doute le premier
bénéficiaire en plus on ne s'exposant
jamais c'est-à-dire en ayant jamais
besoin de parler et d'argumenter on peut
constater qu'il y a deux grands gagnants
à mon sens il y a le Medef et le
rassemblement national et ça c'est un
problème qui est resté silencieux
également un immense défaite de la
gauche
une impasse politique en tout cas c'est
une immense défaite effectivement oui on
peut dire de la gauche mais on peut dire
aussi au fond de la vie démocratique au
sens plus large mais c'est vrai que que
ce soit à la fois le rassemblement
national vous avez raison et le Medef ça
pose un problème et ça montre aussi que
au-delà de la question de la défaite il
y a là un vide il y a là peut-être un
boulevard pour une gauche réformiste
d'où actuellement tout ce qu'on raconte
sur la crise de la nupase c'est-à-dire
que il y a quelque chose qui travaille
sur la façon dont on peut récupérer
l'initiative et l'élan par rapport à
cette dynamique qui a été lancée par la
démocratie sociale par Laurent Berger
syndicaliste réformiste il y a quelque
chose qui montre que la vie politique
française pourrait se reconfigurer
autrement donc ne parlons pas de défaite
mais disons qu'en tout cas la
reconfiguration serait sans doute une
manière de sortir de la crise pour la
gauche alors dans ce débat on est un peu
comme des médecins aux chevets d'une
d'un malade un grand malade la Cinquième
République Richard Berly quand même le
fait de vouloir revenir sur une loi qui
vient alors dans des conditions qu'on
sait mais qui vient d'être adopté à
peine à peine à ou deux mois plus tard
est-ce que c'est pas justement un
symptôme de maladie non je crois pas non
je crois que là pour le ça
je connais un peu parce que on les a
rencontrés à plusieurs reprises avec des
correspondants étrangers vous pouvez
imaginer que c'est une anomalie sur la
carte parlementaire donc ça nous
intéresse moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est
une chose bien évidemment il y a 7
cacophonie du groupe que vous avez cité
qu'ils viennent d'horizon différents
mais tous composés pas forcément quelque
chose voilà tous sont des gens proches
du terrain très proche du terrain et
leur président Bertrand pencher qui je
ne me trompe pas il député de la Meuse
c'est quelqu'un qui qui connaît très
bien sa circonception et moi ça m'a
frappé et je crois que ça c'est quelque
chose qui par exemple les différencie
d'autres groupes politiques et du côté
de la macronie c'est souvent une chose
nous correspondant à l'étranger qui nous
frappe c'est-à-dire la distance
vis-à-vis du terrain cette parenthèse on
peut dire aussi qui travaille leur
élection je suis un peu cynique en
disant ça mais c'est pas totalement faux
quand même il y a par exemple chez eux
un discours alors je n'en mesure pas le
degré de véracité de sincérité mais sur
la démocratie locale sur l'importance de
faculté les gens d'associer les gens
bref moi je trouve que là ils font un
travail quand même d'une certaine
manière assez salutaire dans le contexte
actuel et je ne vois pas pourquoi on
leur reprocherait de déposer une
proposition dans de toute manière on
sait que les chances semblent-ils sont
très limités d'aboutir c'est le jeu
parlementaire il le joue en ce qui me
concerne je trouve que c'est assez
normal mais alors moi je reprends ma
terminologie de fausses promesses qu'on
va pouvoir appliquer au référendum
d'initiatives partagées dans un sens
vous ne nous l'avez expliqué mais très
rapidement j'aurais quand même qu'on
dise qui va se passer imaginons que
cette proposition de loi du groupe iode
soit adoptée à l'Assemblée qu'est-ce qui
se passe après alors déjà il y a loin de
la coupe au lèvres parce qu'il faut
considéré comme étant recevable pour
qu'elle soit recevable financièrement
faudra arriver à lager donc avant
qu'elle soit examinée il y a déjà un
premier temps vous êtes allé trop vite
ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire que ça
veut dire que quand vous faites une
proposition de loi ou un amendement en
tant que parlementaire ça doit être 0
argent supplémentaire que vous prenez
dans les caisses de l'État soit ça
rapporte de l'argent soit c'est notre
financièrement si jamais ça coûte de
l'argent il faut le gager c'est à dire
qu'il faut trouver et d'autres
ressources pour arriver à équilibrer les
comptes là je fais pas un dessin en vous
disant que cette proposition de loi dans
ses conséquences elle va coûter cher
donc comment est-ce que vous arrivez à
gager si jamais c'est pas bien gagé si
jamais c'est jugé comme étant soumis au
0cevabilité financières la commission
des finances écarte d'accord
premièrement première étape première
obstacle voilà ensuite il faut trouver
une majorité sans n'a pas fini de
compter on a un mois devant nous on n'a
pas fini ensuite faut trouver une
majorité et la majorité évidemment elle
est pas si évidente mais elle est
potentiellement trouvable si jamais il y
a une adoption de cette proposition de
loi c'est quand même un petit
traumatisme politique pour le
gouvernement et c'est ce que je cherche
les oppositions fondamentalement c'est
pas tant de voir la proposition de loi
aboutir et c'est pour ça que je parle de
fausses promesses bien sûr parce que il
y a une grande partie de l'opinion qui
se dit peut-être qu'on va réussir à
revenir sur cette sur les 64 ans c'est
très propre c'est très peu probable
parce que une fois que elle est adoptée
dans le scénario imaginé elle arrive au
Sénat et je doute que Bruno Retailleau
d'ici là est le groupe LR au Sénat se
disent que la retraite à 62 ans c'est
une bonne idée donc ce faisant si jamais
le Sénat à votre contre qu'est-ce et
bien Elisabeth borne peut éventuellement
court-circuiter le Sénat en donnant le
dernier mot à l'Assemblée nationale pour
établir la retraite à 62 ans c'était une
plaisanterie donc évidemment et ça
n'arrivera pas si vous voulez donc la
proposition de loi se rendent et au
Sénat quand même elle serait examinée au
Sénat et donc en effet je rejoins votre
terme de fausses promesses ça veut pas
dire que ça peut pas avoir des
conséquences politiques l'adoption à
l'Assemblée c'est quand même un petit
tremblement de terre évidemment votre
avis là-dessus sur le tremblement de
terre politique parce que c'est plus un
coup politique que peut-être je reprends
quand même votre argumentaire que nous
volonté réelle de de revenir sur cette
ce que je pense c'est que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que du coup les
Français mon peuvent s'intéresser à leur
vie parlementaire chose à laquelle de
longue date ils ne se sont jamais
intéressés je disais en riant que tout
le monde a appris qu'est-ce que ça
voulait dire 49-3 en tout cas beaucoup
plus de gens le savent maintenant et que
du coup cette guérir parce qu'on peut
apparenter ça de la guérilla et puis le
fait qu'un petit groupe comme le disait
Mathieu croissanto au fond deviennent
central c'est assez intéressant dans la
mesure où on était habitué à considérer
nos députés comme
considéré qu'au fond le SMS leur
ordonnant de lever la main et de voter
fonctionner donc il y a une sorte de
liberté
au 62 ans il y aura quand même une
déception de la part des Français
forcément une déception mais ce qui est
intéressant moi je reviens à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur la question du
collectif il me semble que si des
personnalités émergent Charles de cours
sont Bertrand pencher qui les oreilles
imaginé faire la faire les médias il y a
il y a si peu de temps il y a il y a une
vie politique plus intéressante qui
émerge y compris si elle peut créer du
désappointement et en ce sens de la même
manière que Laurent Berger a pris une
importance médiatique qu'il avait déjà
eu mais pas dans le mais je dirais pas
dans le même personnage je trouve que
notre vie politique devient plus
intéressante et que ça nous aide à
sortir de l'idée que la verticalité
fonctionne alors en tout cas c'est mon
avis la deuxième chose promesse c'est le
référendum d'initiative partagée en
cette fin d'après-midi quand on est en
direct sur le public Sénat on attend
l'addition du conseil cautionnelle je à
Jonathan du prix de nous rejoindre tout
de suite
bonsoir Jonathan
on va aller se placer dans l'hypothèse
ou cette
référendum d'initiative partagée a quand
même de fortes chances d'être retoqués
par le Conseil constitutionnel la gauche
table pourtant toujours sur une il faut
l'expliquer deuxième demande plus solide
que la première voilà c'est ça les 250
parlementaires à l'origine de ce recours
ils vont miser en fait sur une demande
un petit peu plus étayée que la première
qui prévoit que soit votée dans le cadre
de ce référendum je cite une
contribution significative des revenus
du capital au financement des retraites
tout l'enjeu en fait c'est que le
Conseil constitutionnel considère que
cette évolution précisément de la
fiscalité et bien soit considéré comme
une vraie réforme de la politique
économique de la nation comme on dispose
l'article 11 alinéa 5 de notre
Constitution et comme lors de leur
première demande de RIP les
parlementaires ils ont quand même
réitéré leur volonté d'interdire
l'instauration d'un âge légal de départ
à la retraite supérieure à 62 ans et
c'est ça qui avait été retoqué
14 avril dernier par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais en tout cas ce
matin sur notre antenne le ministre de
la transition écologique Christophe
Béchu et bien il était plutôt confiant
que ce soit rotokano écoutez redoutez ne
change rien la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel et ensuite je pense que
les raisons pour lesquelles le premier
référendum d'initiative populaire a été
écarté conduiront sans doute au rejet du
deuxième ce serait présomptueux d'aller
expliquer que
il y aurait en quelque sorte un âge
limite de départ en retraite qu'on ne
pourrait pas dépasser quel que soit les
circonstances que nous rencontrerons une
génération doit pas se dire qu'elle va
fixer une sorte de borne ou de limite
indépassable deuxième échec en trois
semaines est-ce que ça veut dire que
cette procédure de de RIP préfère la
dominative partagée un cadeau empoisonné
dans notre Constitution mais en tout cas
Thomas beaucoup se le demandent à vous
parler d'une fausse promesse mais en
tout cas c'est sûr que depuis sa mise en
œuvre depuis la révision
constitutionnelle sous Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2008 le rythme a été validé qu'une
seule fois par le Conseil
constitutionnel pour contester
privatisation d'Aéroport de Paris
c'était entre 2019 et 2020 et même une
fois cette procédure validée par le
Conseil constitutionnel c'est là que ça
se complique il faut recueillir les
signatures de 4,8 millions de personnes
qui sont inscrites sur les listes
électorales ça fait environ 10% de notre
corps électoral autant dire que c'est
plus ou moins un chemin de croix et
d'autant qu'à l'époque sur le débat ADP
qu'on avait suivi aussi au Sénat des
parlementaires de tout bord et bien ils
taxaient le gouvernement d'entraver la
mise en oeuvre de ce recueil des
signatures écoutées à l'époque cet
échange du côté du gouvernement depuis
une semaine c'est silence radio comment
comptez-vous élargir la communication
grand public allez-vous organiser une
grande campagne d'informations civique
la loi ne l'a pas autorisé tout comme
elle n'a pas autorisé non plus le
financement de parti politique qui
pourrait mener cette campagne là j'ai
envoyé un télégramme à tous les préfets
pour que chaque maire qui sollicite un
agrément entre guillemets agrément
puisse évident mettre ses outils en
place
et donc on le rappelle ce rythme n'avait
pas pu aboutir à l'époque non ça n'avait
pas abouti Thomas et vous allez voir
d'ailleurs sur ces images il y avait eu
quand même un million un de signatures
au terme de la campagne référendaire
c'était vous le voyez tous ces
parlementaires là devant l'Assemblée
nationale je me souviens j'y étais
c'était une victoire en soi pour ses
opposants en tout cas ça marquait une
forme de mécontentement quand même par
le volume de signature en tout cas on
était quand même très loin du compte des
4 millions 8 de signatures en tout cas à
l'époque ça avait relancé le débat sur
l'abaissement du nombre de signatures
pour déclencher cette procédure Emmanuel
Macron n'y était pas défavorable mais en
tout cas depuis le début de son second
quinquennat et ben on en a pas vraiment
entendu parler et en tout cas vous en
parliez c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui la
gauche mise sur le 8 juin avec cette
proposition de loi du groupe liote et au
Sénat ici il y a aussi des
parlementaires communistes qui planchent
sur une proposition de loi merci
beaucoup Jonathan alors faut se promesse
je voudrais bien vous entendre Benjamin
Morel sur le cadre du référendum
d'initiative partagée on a l'impression
donc il a été inventé pour surtout pas
fonctionner quoi exactement vous avez
bien résumé la chose c'est vraiment ça
quoi en 2008 on se dit ce serait quand
même bien de faire un peu de référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et donc on va
introduire quelque chose dans la
Constitution mais on veut surtout pas
que ça soit utilisé parce qu'on ne
voudrait pas que et bien le peuple
contredise les parlementaires souvenez
vous on est quand même trois ans après
le référendum de 2005 et donc on crée
une usine à gaz qui est probablement
sans équivalent au monde en tout cas je
vois pas d'autres équivalent qui fait
que c'est pas un référendum il Satis
citoyenne vous avez besoin de
parlementaire c'est parlementaire et ben
par définition ils sont à l'origine donc
c'est pas vraiment citoyen ensuite il y
a un contrôle de consuualité c'est bien
sauf que on dit que et bien il faut que
ça porte sur une disposition qui ne
remet pas en cause une loi qui a été qui
a été promulgué depuis moins d'un an
c'est pour ça que le Conseil aujourd'hui
est dans des difficultés pour arriver à
valider un rythme parce que la plupart
du temps bah c'est la proposition de loi
ou le projet de loi qui lance une
réflexion et un débat et ça c'est
totalement contre intuitif parce que
dans la plupart des pays on a ce qu'on
appelle des rips abrogatives c'est
notamment le cas en Suisse
une sorte de référendum veto quoi c'est
un peu ça d'accord
vous savez ça existe dès la Révolution
française sous la Révolution française
dans les conditions gérondines et
montagnarde vous avez cette idée le
peuple et bien est détenteur de la
souveraineté les gouvernants peuvent
essayer de deviner la volonté générale
mais s'il se trompe le peuple doit
pouvoir leur dire non donc c'est la base
du référendum cette citoyenne on
l'interdit on ne veut pas de ça ensuite
vous avez 4 millions 900000 signatures
10% du corps électoral pays équivalent
l'Italie 500 000 oui à peu près ça
existe le seuil est à 500 m exactement
et donc on a des disproportions folles
qui fait que c'est quasiment à part le
Dakota il y a pas aux États-Unis il y a
pas d'équivalent en terme de nombre de
signatures et quand bien même vous ayez
vos 4 millions 900000 signatures vous
dites là quand même je suis arrivé au
bout d'une course gigantesque en fait
non le gouvernement et le Parlement si
jamais le texte est soumis au Parlement
et examiné et rejeté par l'une des deux
chambres et examinée par l'autre chambre
et bien véto c'est à dire que le
Parlement des moments où il examine le
texte à la possibilité de être fin alors
de le faire s'il y a 4 millions de
personnes qui ont signé et c'est toute
la limite de la chose parce qu'en
réalité en faisant ça le constituant de
2008 c'est dit au moins je me garde une
marge de veto mais admettons que là le
rip soit validé admettons que vous ayez
4 millions de cent mille signatures
imaginez ce qui se passe dans quelques
mois vous avez un parlement qui aura le
choix entre dire au marché aux agences
de notation je laisse aller le
référendum vous voyez déjà comment ça se
passe mal avec fiches on verra ce que ça
donne ou bien alors faut le dire là j'en
suis qui vient de baisser la dégrader la
note de la France de A à moi donc je
laisse aller refaire un homme et
qu'importe les conséquences économiques
potentielles ou bien et bien je décide
de dire 4 millions de signatures je n'en
ai cure et il est là encore
litthiquement on en paye le briser la
crise démocratique donc c'est en réalité
une fausse bonne idée et un vrai danger
que sa disposition dans la Constitution
plein de pays européens sont au
rythiques plein de d'États américains
sont horroriques il y a jamais eu de
désastres avec des RICS on peut discuter
ensuite des cadres mais ce qu'on a créé
avec le rip et malheureusement je crains
que ce soit une source d'espoir qui
risque d'être longtemps déçu Lucy speed
votre avis là-dessus parce que ça vient
des des parties des oppositions de
gauche et donc voilà est-ce que ils
agissent pas un faux espoir pour les
Français là aussi ben je pense
qu'effectivement il se saisissent de
toutes les opportunités je crois qu'il y
a l'idée de d'essayer de montrer qu'on
s'oppose jusqu'au bout à la réforme
après ce qui est intéressant dans ce que
disait Benjamin Morel c'est le fait
qu'on ait pu introduire je rappelle que
là c'était pas la gauche qu'il a
introduit quelque chose d'aussi mal
ficelé dans la Constitution et que donc
d'une certaine manière il y avait l'idée
qu'on disait quelque chose sur le
symbole et puis qu'au fond concrètement
on s'en fichait et donc ça je trouve que
c'est dans sa conception et dans son
usage c'est qu'en fait en droit il faut
s'intéresser à la pratique du droit à
son application pour ne pas alimenter
vous savez cette méfiance traditionnelle
en France entre les élites ceux qui font
le droit ceux qui sont représentés voilà
les hauts fonctionnaires administration
le pouvoir politique et puis le peuple
ils sont là parce que le peuple leur a
donné mandat d'être là et dans cette
réforme constitutionnelle on vous
parliez on savait d'emblée à mon avis
que ça n'allait pas pouvoir être
praticable mais c'était l'idée de le
montrer de la même que sur la convention
citoyenne pour le climat par exemple
lorsqu'Emmanuel Macron dit on va
appliquer les propositions sans filtre à
partir du moment où on est quand même
une démocratie parlementaire certes
hybride parce que on a aussi un
président élu au suffrage universel on
sait qu'il faudra un moment remettre les
parlementaires dans le jeu donc on a une
manière en France de faire des fausses
promesses au peuple à la société sur la
manière dont on va organiser la
possibilité d'une initiative et d'une
prise de décision populaire et ça c'est
pas possible de le faire mais ça tient
pas à la gauche je crois que c'est une
culture assez largement partagée ma
question c'était vraiment ponctuellement
dans la façon de proposer un premier
si la gauche en fait utilise toutes les
armes qui sont dans sa possession si ça
permet au peuple et à ses représentants
de gauche de se rapprocher dans un
combat commun y compris s'il est s'il
n'about ça peut être un processus le
début d'un processus alors on va aller
au-delà de cette décision du Conseil
conscient en se posant la question de
l'utilisation plus générale du
référendum dans notre fonctionnement
démocratique et notamment sur la
question des retraites je vous propose
un
témoignage puisque je le disais tout à
l'heure depuis l'utilisation du 49-3 on
peut dire que le mouvement un peu changé
de nature il y a des manifestants qui
réclament une démocratie plus directe
comme cet enseignant en Lycée
Professionnel on l'écoute
j'attends plus rien pour une démocratie
plus directe comprennent la vie des
citoyens quoi faudrait un référendum sur
cette question et là les gens se
prononcent ça passe ça passe pas mais il
y aurait plus de discussion et je pense
que ça se paiera dans les urnes et pour
moi c'est très très pareil c'est très
sombre le Front national monte de plus
en plus et pour moi c'est pas une
solution
alors je me sens évidemment vers vous
Richard Verly parce que ça se passe
comme ça on suit à quel point on utilise
le référendum où les votations à tous
les points à tous les domaines même sur
des questions très très pointues parce
que vous avez quatre journées de
votation en Suisse par an et lors de ces
journées de votation qui ont lieu à
chaque fois un dimanche vous avez toute
une série de votations c'est pour ça
qu'elles sont au pluriel qui sont
proposés aux électeurs du niveau
communal jusqu'au niveau fédéral donc il
peut y avoir des questions communales
des questions cantonales puisque vous
savez que le pays est divisé en canton
ou des questions fédérales et la vérité
c'est que ça marche alors ça marche
attention et ça il faut bien comprendre
il faut comprendre d'abord que le
système suisse contrairement à la
réputation qu'il a n'est pas un système
de démocratie directe pur c'est un
système hybride puisqu'il y a aussi un
parlement qui délibère qui prend des
lois et toutes les lois fort
heureusement non ne font pas l'objet
d'un veto par référendum ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il y a une longue tradition
référendaire et que cette tradition
référendaire elle fonctionne d'autant
plus le pays est très décentralisé ça
c'est important à le rappeler également
mais prenez les retraites moi j'entends
beaucoup depuis le début et ça dure
depuis le mois de janvier cette cette
affaire des retraites dire en France on
ne peut pas voter sur les retraites
c'est trop compliqué
à au moins deux reprises en Suisse sur
les retraites récemment une fois pour
mettre l'âge à 65 ans pour les hommes et
pas pour les femmes une fois pour
ramener les femmes à 65 ans également
c'était récemment c'était en septembre
2022 ça s'est très bien passé vous savez
quand vous êtes électeur en Suisse vous
recevez à peu près un mois avant la date
de la votation un petit livret dans
votre boîte aux lettres qui vous
explique l'objet de toutes les votations
sur laquelle vous allez devoir vous
exprimer et à chaque fois vous avez
l'argumentaire du gouvernement donc le
Conseil fédéral en Suisse et
l'argumentaire des tenants de la
position inverse et bien croyez-moi on
peut expliquer une réforme des retraites
on peut l'expliquer de manière claire et
on peut expliquer aux gens qu'elles en
seront les conséquences quand même
dernier petit dernière nuance on suit
s'il y a un frein constitutionnel à
l'endettement l'endettement public
c'est-à-dire que vous ne pouvez pas
prendre des mesures qui augmenteraient
de manière sensible la dette publique on
peut comprendre de qu'en France ce
serait une limite réelle
Mathieu et puis en France l'utilisation
du référendum en tout cas le vote au
référendum parfois été un peu dévoyé et
culturellement politiquement à cause de
la personnalisation de la Miss France
politique française et notamment du rôle
du président de la République on se dit
souvent que les gens ne répond pas
forcément la question mais
votre oui ou non en fonction de ce que
vous prenez par exemple le référendum de
2005 c'est très intéressant prenez les
enquêtes CSA au moins sur le sur
l'Europe
prenez l'enquête CSA de courbe de
popularité Jacques Chirac elle est de
36% au mois de novembre elle est de 36%
au mois de mars entre temps prenez les
enquêtes Ipsos sur le le traité consuel
européen le oui passe de 65 à 45%. donc
dire les en 2005 ont voté pour contre
Chirac pas vraiment en réalité il y a
une vraie politisation d'électorat
et ça va être sous de Gaulle il y a un
aspect plébiscitaire mais même je suis
de Gaulle l'aspect plébiscitaire est
passé évident il y a plusieurs jeux
pour dire que l'exploitation politique à
laquelle vous faites référence du
référendum elle existe elle a existé en
Suisse c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai que
certains partis politiques si la cause
est une cause facile à enflammer je
pense notamment à l'interdiction des
minarets non pas des mosquées mais des
minarets qui a eu lieu en Suisse et qui
a été voté changement constitutionnel en
2009 il y a eu une exploitation
politique de cette cause c'est évident
mais encore une fois il apprentissage
démocratique qui va avec le référendum
me semble quand même extrêmement
salutaire alors votre avis là-dessus on
cherche à redonner un peu de souffle à
notre démocratie peut-être pour
commencer Benjamin Morel et ensuite je
viens vers vous est-ce que voilà le fait
de de finalement banaliser l'usage du
référendum ça pourrait être une solution
alors il faut pas non plus trop le
banaliser je parle sur le contrôle de -1
mais ensuite il y a une telle anal
fortement parric jamais aucun et il y a
eu des RICS sur ces sujets jamais aucun
État américain n'a rétablit la peine de
mort ou interdit l'avortement via un RIC
donc parfois
il faut savoir faire confiance au peuple
et quand on lui donne les bons moyens
pour délibérer bah souvent il fait pas
n'importe quoi Lucie Schmitt votre avis
est-ce que est-ce que ça fait partie des
outils de démocratie directe ou
participative que vous vous espérez voir
ce développé en France ou est-ce que
vous n'y croyez pas finalement
écoutez je serais peut-être un peu plus
nuancé mais en tout cas ce que j'observe
c'est que la personne qui était
interrogée disait qu'elle ne croyait
plus qu'au référendum parce qu'elle
avait perdu confiance dans tout le reste
de la vie démocratique donc je pense que
si le référendum est la seule chose qui
nous reste c'est un problème c'est à
dire que moi j'espère qu'en tout cas
aller voter pour son député aller voter
pour élire le maire enfin ça restera
quelque chose d'important et j'espère
aussi que notre vie démocratique ne se
résout pas au référendum aux élections
qu'il y a d'autres occasions notamment
des débats les médias joue un rôle
important alors ensuite par rapport à ce
que disait Benjamin Morel moi je
réfléchissais comme je suis écologiste
au référendum pour Notre Dame des Landes
vous savez qu'il y avait donné une
majorité pour le fait de de construire
l'aéroport et qui ensuite Édouard
Philippe est intervenu quelques temps
après en disant que le consensus
démocratique n'existait pas sur ce plan
il a pas du tout évoqué d'ailleurs la
question écologique la difficulté si
vous voulez c'est que des procédures à
l'époque on a dit au fond c'était pas la
bonne échelle est-ce que construire cet
aéroport est-ce que c'était pas un sujet
national est-ce qu'il fallait pas au
contraire en faire un sujet encore plus
local donc on ne savait pas très bien
non seulement comment poser la question
mais quelle était la dimensionnement
l'échelle qu'il fallait utiliser et puis
par rapport à ce que dirichard ce qui
est intéressant c'est l'idée qu'on
reçoit la documentation et qu'au fond de
la même manière que pour ce qui s'était
passé en reconnaissance on dessine en
connaissance de cause et rappelez-vous
que pour le référendum de 2005 qui a
rejeté la Constitution européenne le TCE
il y a eu des mois de discussion et donc
on est dans une situation ou sur une
question extrêmement complexe il faut
prendre le temps de discuter ce qui
n'est jamais le cas dans une campagne
électorale on voit que des campagnes
électorales de plus en plus son contenu
avec des slogans et ce qui n'est jamais
le cas d'une certaine manière de la part
des camps en présence donc comment
est-ce qu'on reprend l'initiative au
fond d'organiser des débats de contenu
c'est certainement une manière de
refaire de la vie démocratique mais je
sais que par exemple beaucoup d'écologie
sont très anxieux à l'idée de référendum
en disant au fond les choses sont
caricaturées et la complexité n'arrivera
pas à être représentée moi je crois
qu'on y arrivera un remède de la
complexité dans le référendum mais ce
sera aller contre la tradition française
ou c'était blanc noir pour de Gaulle
contre de Gaulle comme le disait Mathieu
croissanto la difficulté qu'on avait à
créer des coalitions ça va peut-être
être difficile d'aller aussi contre
cette autre dramatique une tradition
française
du référendum aujourd'hui elle est un
peu biaisée et c'est une arme plutôt de
dernière ressort c'est à dire quand le
politique ne prend pas sur lui de
trancher au nom des citoyens qui est
censé représenter mais il leur refile le
bébé soit parce que c'est compliqué soit
parce que c'est un enjeu de société tel
que il faut associer tout le monde mais
il y a un côté utilisé en dernier
ressort moi je pense que la levrez débat
c'est plutôt comment on réussit à
élaborer plus collectivement des
décisions c'est dans l'élaboration de la
décision au départ que ça se joue après
comment on l'adopte est-ce que c'est les
Français qu'on parle est-ce que c'est
leur présentation du peuple c'est autre
chose et c'est en ce sens-là que même si
les conventions citoyennes pour
l'instant Taton elles ont leurs défauts
on a vu avec ce qui s'est passé sur la
Convention sur le climat c'est vrai ou
la parole des citoyens eux ont cru
qu'ils allaient faire la loi et Emmanuel
Macron leur a donné laissé entendre
qu'il la ferait donc là il y a eu un
hiatus mais avec celle sur la fin de vie
vous voyez déjà que dans l'élaboration
de la décision
quand on peut associer des gens venus de
tous horizons et d'une certaine d'un
certain point de vue dépassionnés et des
politisés au sens partisan du terme mais
peut-être que les choses peuvent mieux
se passer après alors justement je
rebondisse le mail de nous dire avec un
autre témoignage celui d'un d'un tout
jeune participant à cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat donc la
convention elle se déroule en 2019 il
témoigne quelques mois plus tard il a 17
ans il s'appelle Nicolas améglio et il y
a encore pas mal d'espoir écoutez il y a
un détachement il y a un fossé entre
le monde politique et la réalité des
choses cette convention avec des sa
réunit des gens qui s'en foutait
complètement de la politique et donc ça
ça a eu le rôle de de de pont et c'est
ce que je retiens principalement de de
la Convention et c'est ce qui me pousse
aussi voilà à dire qu'il faudrait que
pérenniser ce système là sur 149
propositions il y en a eu 15 reprises
sans filtre pour reprendre la la
formulation du président de la
République 55 ont été votés mais
modifiés alors certains diront édulcorer
et puis plus de la moitié non appliqué
on peut dire que la déception était à la
hauteur de l'espoir
ou alors est-ce que c'est tout
simplement une erreur sémantique du
président de dire sans filtre fallait
pas s'engager à ce point là je pense
qu'en tout cas ça révèle son une forme
du brise de sa part sur le fait que
c'est lui qui décide c'est à dire que il
dit sans filtre moi je pense que les
citoyens peuvent être vexés mais le
Parlement aussi donc il y a un vrai
sujet sur le fait qu'on est dans un pays
qui a des institutions après si les
citoyens sont déçus par ailleurs comme
le raconte ce jeune participant il y a
eu une espèce d'acculturation et moi ce
que je regrette c'est que les citoyens
ne soient se soient quelque part pas
émanciper du processus on voit que dans
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie il y a eu davantage de liberté des
citoyens et qu'ils ont été capables
peut-être parce que le sujet aussi était
un sujet plus accessible plus ressenti
que sur ces questions écologiques qui
ont été présentées par de nombreux
experts et d'une certaine manière ils
étaient davantage en situation d'élèves
d'apprendre etc sur la voilà ouais voilà
c'était extrêmement vaste avec ces cinq
thématiques et donc de ce fait il me
semble que là peut-être que les citoyens
ont appris à s'émanciper et que c'est
bouton et puis je crois aussi que la
convention citoyenne sur le climat a été
fort utile pour se rendre compte qu'il y
avait la possibilité d'une écologie
populaire en revanche pour terminer pas
d'hypothèse économique pas d'hypothèse
budgétaire pas de modalités un comité
légistique vous savez l'écologie ça se
résout pas au fait de faire des lois
écologiques et du coup je trouve que
l'exercice a été singulièrement rendu
abstrait et expert par le gouvernement
et ça c'était un problème au motif qu'on
faisait de l'écologie populaire qui est
devenu une écologie législative Benjamin
Morel est-ce qu'on peut utiliser ses
conventions citoyennes sans fragiliser
le Parlement oui bien sûr à condition
d'associer le Parlement regarder ce qui
se passe en Belgique germanophones où
vous avez justement ce type de
convention mais vous avez des
parlementaires qui siègent et donc ça
permet de créer des liens entre les
groupes et les conventions ici on oppose
les deux c'est au contraire une façon
souvent pour l'exécutif de
court-circuiter donc évidemment ça plaît
pas au parlementaire et on peut les
entendre après pour aucune convention
citoyenne fonctionne quand vous regardez
un petit peu ce qui se passe à
l'étranger il y a toujours trois
conditions il faut un sujet de valeur
c'est à dire les sujets techniques c'est
pas un sujet à convention la fin de vie
l'avortement là en effet c'est des
sujets qui fonctionnent bien il faut un
débouché et très intéressant de voir le
modèle de l'Ohio
en noyau on ne pose pas justement
convention et référendum quand vous avez
un référendum initiative citoyenne qui
est lancé on réunit une convention et la
convention et bien elle a pour but de
construire des arguments et ses
argumentaires ensuite permettent de
délibérer ça évite justement l'effet
plébiscite et enfin dernier point pour
que ça fonctionne et bien il faut que
votre convention elle est je dirais une
capacité de délibération technique qui
fait que elle est accompagnée comme il
faut elle est accompagnée sur des sujets
qui vont être des sujets quand même
relativement simple en tout cas
accessible parce que vous ne devenez pas
un spécialiste de physique nucléaire en
six mois ça pour le coup c'est très
populiste donc si vous avez ces trois
conditions si vous vouliez ça un
référendum oui ça peut marcher et encore
une fois ça marche ailleurs et on n'est
pas un petit village gaulois ce qui
fonctionne ailleurs peut fonctionner
aussi chez nous Richard Werly il y a on
peut dire que le président essaye je
sais pas si le SI ça me fait avec toute
sa santé sincérité mais il y a aussi le
Conseil national de la refondation qui a
été très lancé à l'aspect le dernier à y
croire dans ce pays mais il y a des
tentatives de de renouveau démocratique
de la part d'Emmanuel Macron alors vous
pensez que il fait semblant alors on
doit être deux à y croire parce que je
dois être l'un des seuls correspondant
étrangers à avoir dit que c'était une
bonne idée un conseil national le
refondation qui grosso modo a été très
critiquée je pense qu'il y a il y a des
idées que les idées elles méritent
d'être étudiées elles mérite d'être mise
en oeuvre il y aurait rien de pire que
de s'opposer d'emblée à l'idée moi je
retiens ce que vous avez dit c'est très
vrai une consultation appelons sa
démocratie participative citoyenne je
dirais peu importe mais qui qui serait
vu comme confisquant le droit au peuple
de s'exprimer ça ce serait très
dangereux de dire il y a 150 citoyens
tirés au sort qui vont décider à votre
place par contre liés une période de
réflexion comme vous le disiez
d'élaboration populaire je sais pas si
on peut appeler utiliser ce terme et
ensuite
aller vers le peuple à travers
référendum ça je pense que ce serait
sans doute la bonne solution avec quand
même encore une fois un rappel un
référendum le résultat peut être très
juste
50, quelque chose on l'a eu ensuite sur
des sujets très importants typiquement
l'appartenance à l'Union européenne
rejoindre ou non la Communauté
européenne à l'époque le résultat était
très très faible en faveur de ceux qui
ont fusée et ça a été accepté c'est là
que je veux dire c'est qu'il faut
s'accepter il faudrait donc imaginer que
toutes les formations politiques
s'engagent préalablement à respecter le
résultat d'un référendum on va terminer
là-dessus merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
à bientôt sur public